hey everybody is Jessie today we're
going to build some reactive components
let's see what we have so far since
yesterday
haven't really added that much I think I
added a few more pages and some
component names about it in some
components I'll show you what's going on
this is the reacts and if this is the
react side so we have a component now
for this hero section and we have a
component for this this nav which is
actually separate and for this sticky
nav we also have a component for the
footer so now we need to fill in some of
the other stuff but you can see it looks
nearly identical the only big change I
want I want your opinion on this had a
meeting this morning so I see I didn't
get that much done between yesterday and
today because today was filled mostly
with meetings and paperwork and
reviewing applications and we're hiring
we're actually going to hire a web
developer so if anybody's interested in
that position you have web development
experience let me know
I guess send me send me a message on
Twitter or I guess you put in the
comments below if you're interested but
I changed so in a meeting today it was
mentioned that you know we wanted more
of like a cursive type font so the font
on the right is what we had and that's
this
same font that we're using for the that
most of the H tags and then this is the
font that I'm trying out I'm not really
sure and at this point I'm ready to move
on and not mess with fonts anymore so if
you guys have an opinion about fonts let
me know comment put in the live chat if
you think there's another font that
would be better let me know I'm I'm
trying to stick you know with google
fonts there's you know some free fonts
they're widely available basically what
I'm looking for is something similar to
this like a handwriting font that's very
let's say kind of formal and thin so if
you have a font in mind the one on the
rights more legible right okay so I was
reading from the from the live chat we
have some comments at the one on the
right is more legible yeah I I like the
one on the right but I think I'm gonna I
don't know I might lose this one here
and have to go with the font that looks
more like this so we'll see maybe I'll
try out a couple of fonts present them
all at the next meeting and see you know
see what people think so I mean I I do
kind of like this one but sometimes you
know you got to go you can't always make
all the decisions on a site and other
other people involved usually so thanks
for the input
yeah it looks like a lot of people like
the one on the right we have some people
who do like the one on the left okay all
right I'm going to move these over so
you can show you more what's going on if
if you weren't watching yesterday I'll
give you a quick recap we had a static
website that we built and you just saw
some of it on the screen when I show you
the different fonts
we're converting that website into a
react website we install a react
yesterday locally using next Jas which
helps us install it very quickly we got
everything installed and we actually had
you know a page up and running in less
than a half an hour so super quick I
have links to all that in the show
description so now the task is just to
convert everything so next I'll show you
what we have here next has a folder for
pages and it handles all the routing for
you if you put files in the pages folder
so let me show you in this pages folder
each one of these is going to be a
different page and if I just if I go to
that page and the address in the address
bar it will just automatically route to
that page very convenient and then your
components can go in whatever folder you
want I have an in folder named
components and that's pretty much it
next also handles server-side rendering
which is awesome it does a lot of other
cool stuff too and we'll probably get
into more that as we build things out
all right it seems like from the live
chat everybody likes the one on the
right all right at the next meeting I'm
going to try really hard to convince
everybody that we should go with the one
on the right I think readability is
probably the best reason I do think it
looks better in general also it's one
less font we have to load since we're
already loading it so maybe I'll come in
with some tangerine from hey that's
awesome you know what that font was that
is the tangerine fun that's crazy I
don't know that I could
just bought a font and know what it was
right off the bat so that's you have a
really good eye somebody in the last
room knew exactly what this font was oh
yeah they're saying less less font
defend dependencies better performance
that's that's what I'm thinking so okay
I think I have some good reasons to make
a case for the font that was on the
right so I'm going to try that my next
meeting
actually I'm going to let you guys know
next week I have meetings during my
normal livestream time on Monday and
Tuesday so Tuesday will be the next
meeting we'll discuss this website then
on Wednesday Thursday and Friday I'll be
gone the syntax con conference in South
Carolina is going to be that at the end
of next week so I will be there I'm
thinking about doing some live streams
from the conference Oh we'll see how it
goes I'm not really sure how the Wi-Fi
is going to be so I may just do some
recordings and then upload them when I
get a chance to get somewhere with with
good Wi-Fi but it might be cool to do
some live streams so next week is going
to be kind of a weird week I'm going at
Monday and Tuesday I'll just reschedule
the live streams for maybe earlier in
the day and stuff like so many meetings
coming up next week I don't know about
you guys but I could code all day but
you put me in a meeting for an hour and
it just drains me so I don't know what
it is about meetings
all right let's get let's get back to
this so I want to build some components
so let's just pick out something to
build so I already have some components
built and I have other ones that I I
don't have build at all so let's check
out this team card so this one's blank
this will be a nice one to build up so
let me show you what we're going to
build first and then we'll build it and
you see it's it's super easy to convert
existing HTML into a component depending
on the amount of act you know
interactivity that component has it
could be a little bit more complicated
but in this case what we're going to do
is not going to be that complicated so
let me bring this over okay so if you
remember I don't know if I made these a
lot I don't think I made these live but
I'm pretty sure I at least showed this
section okay I did do a video where we
we made this little hide and show
section so we have these cards at the
meeting this morning
these were big hit and the way this
section works so I was happy about that
because this was kind of the design of
this was one of the most kind of made up
parts I say that is I try to follow
material design mostly but this kind of
thing was not it's kind of off the path
it's not really spelled out in material
design so when I go out and get a little
creative on my own like that it's always
I don't know it's always a little
stressful for me to see you know whether
it's going to work or not but in this
case it worked out we're actually going
to convert another part of the site to
use a similar system won't do that in
this video but this is what we're going
to take so let me find the code for this
and we'll copy it over
if someone's asked saying they need help
with react native so yeah I haven't
worked with react native yet I watch
some videos on it and read about it and
I'm super interested in it but I haven't
had an opportunity to work with it and I
should say this as well I am no expert
on react I haven't built very many
things with react I have built sites
that are that are live that have
launched that are working with react but
I'm still very much learning a lot of
the you know kind of the react way to do
things so if you have used react
I'm sure you'll spot some things that
that I could be doing better and go
ahead and let me know in the comments so
let me know in the live chat if if you
see something that could be done better
I'll try to incorporate your suggestions
I will have a repo up for this react
site soon right now it just exists
locally I'm actually not even tracking
it with it at this point since I just
started it but I will soon and as soon
as I put that up I'll put the link to
the new repo in the description for the
video the repo for the static site that
were we're converting is is up it is on
github and you can check that up so on
my other screen which you can't see I'm
just finding the code that we wrote the
the markup for those little cards for
some reason my it's going a little slow
so I apologize I'm like trying to scroll
when it's just not it's not scrolling
fast so I don't know I'm going to I
actually went through today and closed a
lot of the windows that I wasn't using
but it's still giving me a little bit of
trouble
alright so we're going to grab
I'll grab some of those code
and actually let me paste just to help
us out we'll copy this section over so
you don't have to type all this up and
we'll change the name so he says class
you're going to use the name of your
component two places up here at the top
and then down here where you export it
to name it here and then you export it
here so we'll type in the name of team
cards and now we'll copy in the mark-up
now I'll show you there's just a few
things that you absolutely have to
change or you're going to get an error
so you have some weird spacing things
well I have a weird spacing things
alright that looks better okay so when
you copy over something in Iraq you
can't use class you have to use class
name so I'll go through everywhere where
I've used class and just put class name
at the end and also we have to have
closing tags for everything so I'm glad
this is in here this is a good example
this image tag let me make this bigger I
think I shrunk this down after the video
yesterday to give me more space so they
make this bigger there we go okay I'm
kind of ignoring a live chat a little
bit so I can get through this so I
apologize for that I'll try to check
back in a minute and see if there's any
questions okay I just had this helmet
it's as nice pasting by the way class
name yet if you're not familiar with
Adam it Adams not the only editor that
can do this a lot other editors can but
it has this cool feature which you know
multiple cursors so I highlight the
and an atom on Mac I press command-d and
then it just keeps going down and and
now I have all these cursors so I can
type backspace you could even if if I
had copied something I could paste it in
there but I think the last thing I copy
it was all that code if I tried to pay
so now be a mess but it really comes in
handy it saves a lot of time from having
the you know edit those by hand you can
accomplish a similar thing by you know
find and replace but that just is a lot
quicker at least for me if I had like
hundreds of things I would I would do
find a replace but if it's like 10 or or
fewer then I use the multiple cursors so
anyway this image tag will this will
give me an error so actually let's let's
just make it give the error first just
to show you what it looks like again
error and react and then we'll fix it so
first I need to link this up right now
this component exists but it's not
linked up to any page so we need to put
it in a page so the only page right now
that I really have built out at all is
this index page so if we'll see here at
the top we're importing all the
components that we need I don't know if
there's an easier way to import these
than one on each line if there is let me
know because I would rather not have a
separate line for every component but
you can see all I'm doing is saying here
what the name of the component is and
then I'm saying where their component
lives at in our file structure so we
named our component team cards why don't
I name it cards it should be singular
what was I thinking this is going to bug
lis so I'm just going to change it real
quick because this is not going to be
more than one card this is just one card
so I'm going to say that I'm going to
rename this
okay now there we go
okay so now that we've imported it here
we're free to use it down here so inside
of this this render function that's
where we put our HTML so let's go ahead
and throw this down below that sticky
enough and all we're going to do is just
put it in HTML tag team code and
remember we have to close that up
but in this case we are we're trying to
get an error so I'm going to save this
and then I'm going to bring over I'm
going to bring this over okay let me let
me make this Biggs you can see it's
super small right now error messages in
react are awesome they're very
descriptive they tell you exactly where
the error is so it says we have a syntax
error they expected a closing tag for
image and it tells you exactly where it
is and then it actually shows you the
code so it says you know basically it
got to here and was confused because it
didn't see what it expected to see so we
can look back right before that we say
okay we have this image tag and we never
close that image tag so a lot of the
times when you get an error in react it
will be pretty easy to fix it so let's
go back over here we'll go to our team
card and let's just close this up all we
have to do is just add that slash in and
I'm going to save it and go back there
we go okay so we see the team card right
now we're not seeing the image because I
need to change the image path okay but
it's basically a team card the reason it
looks all huge like this is because I
didn't put it inside our container
that's going to constrain its its width
so I have to make a decision I guess
whether I want the team card to come
built in with that container or whether
I want to put in that container in the
page or maybe in another component I
guess I don't have to make that decision
right now the only reason I don't want
to put the container here is I would
rather have the freedom to use these
cards in different sized containers so a
half with container full with a third
width of the page
okay I'm saying Fabian in the live
stream is putting in some stuff I'm not
I'm not exactly sure what you're trying
to say if Fabian so maybe leave a
comment for me and explain it more okay
so we have about 10 minutes left so
let's fix this Wow okay I don't know why
that image didn't work actually I had I
just thought that I gave it the wrong
path but this should work because it's
not pointing to a local image it's
pointing to this other website hmm all
right I'm just going to inspect this
quickly just to see and this is this is
kind of the point of the the livestream
is to show the times where things go
wrong because I mean that's what
realistic usually in my day-to-day work
you know thinks things don't work like I
want them to the first time you know
sometimes that happens often and you
gotta figure out what's going on hmm
yeah I'm not exactly sure I'll show you
what I'm what I'm seeing here I can make
this a little bigger okay so maybe you
see something that I don't see but this
looks this looks like it should work
maybe I could check okay I have crazy
stuff going on now and the console
I'll show you this error is coming from
that sticky nerve I think this is
because I keep resizing the screen and
it's it it thinks the stickeen app
should be there and it keeps looking for
it so let me refresh to get rid of some
of that and then we can look so you see
I have all kinds of weird stuff
happening if you guys know I mean some
of these errors are obvious I'm just not
loading in fonts where I should be right
now which which is okay I'm not worried
about that at this point I'm getting
this error here this SW so like
serviceworker I guess I'm not exactly
sure what's going on with that error if
anybody knows let me know in the
comments and that would be helpful
otherwise you know I'm going to look it
up if this just happens in development
and then on production it's not a big
deal then I'm not that worried about it
oh okay when we were trying to get this
thing it resulted trying at that image
resulted in a error the promise was
rejected okay I'll figure that out later
on yeah that's it this is fetch event
network your response okay yeah you guys
you guys saw it before I did so someone
else named Jesse in the live stream saw
that before I did okay somebody asked
about the dark theme in the Google
Chrome console as well and somebody
mentioned react dev tools yeah I do have
the react dev tools
installed they are very helpful the dark
theme you just go under the settings for
dev tools there's a setting you can
either pick the the light theme of the
dark theme yes hello Jessie it's kind of
weird to see my name in the in the
stream but that's cool thanks for
watching welcome alright so let's see if
we can get in about five minutes if we
can get another component built and
maybe it might be cool to maybe make a
component that imports another component
so let me see if I have one zero four I
might just have to make a new one let me
go back here components let's uh let's
make a not sure if I want this to be a
component I need something like this at
some point so let's try it out so we're
going to make section did I not make
yeah it showed up here okay it's going
to make section a component first I'm
going to copy this you see this is this
is pretty much how I do components it's
a lot of copying of just the boilerplate
stuff so we don't have to retype it
alright so the section component and
what I want this to do I guess I could
be faster from your copy I'm going to
copy it from the other code
okay so I'm gonna copy a lot of stuff
and we're going to take some out so I
just want the section
you can see
listen to anyone more okay um this will
work and I just want it this is I'm
going to be kind of more like a test
section I'll probably use this at some
point but I'll have to modify it to use
it in the actual site but what I'm going
to do is import that team card into this
section and let's let's shrink it down a
little bit let's let's do m6 so this
will make it you know 50% of the width
of a container and let's put in team
card and then we need to import the team
card so I'm going to copy the import
from index 3 next page
okay this I think this should work
alright so we say that now let's go into
our index page and let's bring in let's
import this section and we'll just we'll
add this in right above the regular team
card okay so I'm going to say that it's
going to refresh and we'll see if we
have any errors where's my oh it's over
here okay so it definitely worked I'm
not exactly sure why the column thing
didn't work I'm checking out and dev
tools here so the section
ah you guys probably caught what just
happened I'll show you I left in these
classes I'm actually really surprised
that I didn't get any any error message
popping up I probably did my console
though so I need to put class name there
lesson is it action is everything too
big I can shrink it down a little bit
let me know if you think the the font is
too big and my editor I think that's
what early you guys are talking about in
the live chat ok let's see if this makes
a difference yes there we go okay so you
can see now we've actually put a
component into another component and
then added that component into a page
and it's basically the same process all
the way through you just have to make
sure you import it you have to say where
you're importing it from and then you
include it down here make sure you have
class maintenance at a class and make
sure you close out all your tags name
your component export your component and
then when you go to put it on page make
sure you import it again and then just
put it where you want on the page now
this is really simple what's going to
end up happening though is at some point
we're not just going to say teen card
we're going to take this team card and
we're going to put it like in a loop
let's say so up here we'll actually
import data from from an API we're going
to use the WordPress API at some point
so all our content is going to live in
you know in WordPress we're going to
call that and it's actually going to
call it on the server render it on the
server and it's just going to loop
through and fill that data into the team
cards as as much data as we have so
we're going to end up with you know
probably 100 cards we're going to sort
them out by section you know by category
but we only have to make the team card
one time so whereas before let me see if
I can show you let me show you the
markup
it's crazy long so the markup I just
switched over this is the static site so
you can see for that that same page
where we have all those cards this is
what it looks like that's a lot to keep
track of we don't want to have to edit
that so now to go back to react all that
has turned into this just one time and
then all this data is just going to be
added in from the API and repeated so
we're still going to get all the cards
we need that you know the on the
client-side and dev tools we would see
all those but we don't have to mess with
it all on our n so that's kind of the
one one of the awesome things about
react it's not like other things can't
do this I mean this is basic templating
stuff here but it is a nice thing a nice
advantage if you're going to use react
or some other templating system over
just having everything you know static
and and hand coded it's alright for
maybe a one page or a small site but if
you start getting a lot of repetitive
elements on the page templating is the
way to go all right I'm going to check
the live chat real quick before we end
just see if I can answer some questions
you guys might have had so I'm going to
scroll through
alright somebody has a question any
advice for landing a job after
graduating from full-stack coding boot
camp my advice would be apply for lots
of jobs even if you don't think you meet
all the requirements
sometimes job descriptions are written
by people in human resources who don't
really know that much about the
technology so they're just given a list
of all the different things that a
person might need they put them all on
that list not realizing how crazy it
sounds and really they don't need
somebody who's an expert in all those
things so I would recommend you know
just just apply apply to places and
always keep doing do side projects if
you can get some freelance work that
would be great but keep building up your
portfolio and for your own website for
your github profile and you know you'll
you'll get a job there's a lot of you
know developer jobs out there so if you
just keep keep it up keep getting better
and keep applying you'll get a job I
just scroll down a little bit and I saw
that somebody else said kind of the same
thing try to pick up freelance works and
contribute to project so I should have
scrolled down a little bit more alright
I'm getting almost to the end of the
live chat okay you clarify it and said
lesson on Chrome I'll remember that for
the next live stream yeah to live
streams ago everybody said make it
bigger so now I made it too big
somebody's asking about the time it
takes to make a website that's entirely
dependent on what kind of website it is
how much content you know what it needs
to do it's entirely possible to make a
one page website in a day depends on
what you're starting with why there's so
many coming soon challenges in free code
camp I don't actually make the challenge
I don't work on those challenges so I'm
not exactly sure I know you know they
want to test them thoroughly and make
sure that they're ready to go before
they release them but here as somebody
also said you can test the challenges on
the beta site if you want to someone
else had a question about Java on free
code camp there is no Java on free code
camp not not that I know of and I'm not
sure somebody just asked why don't they
offer it I'm not sure why it free code
camp they focus on kind of a small set
of things so no there's a lot of other
places out there where you you kind of
similar to the style free code can being
able to do most of it in your browser
and things like that they do offer it
Java courses ok I think I got through
everything and all the questions if I
missed your question put it in the
comments and I'll get to it later on let
me know if there's anything I need to
explain more in the video if you have
any suggestions for me or you do
anything to improve my live streams and
I will be on again tomorrow same time
2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
thanks for watching I'll see you then